protesters block roads have put up
barricades on the outskirts of the
Ecuadorian capital Quito ahead of a
nationwide strike and mass march planned
on Wednesday we need to rise up until
this problem with fuel prices is
resolved we're not going to give up
we're all going to rise up until the
price of fuel goes down the interior
ministry says hundreds of people have
been arrested since Thursday mainly for
criminal damage despite the unrest
president Lenin Moreno says he has no
plans to reverse his decision to scrap
fuel subsidies as part of strict
austerity measures I am always ready to
hold talks to extend a hand to people
who are decent who are honest who really
want to change the country I am
convinced of dialogue with my indigenous
brothers with whom we share many causes
on how to use the country's resources
for those who need it the most
Maryna who has set ecuador on a centrist
path after years of socialist rule says
austerity measures are necessary to
reduce Ecuador's foreign debt and fiscal
deficit in February his government
signed a four billion dollar loan
agreement with the International
Monetary Fund but scepticism of the IMF
runs strong in Ecuador they are going to
Quito they are arriving to hit on
Wednesday just for the fuel prices but
if the situation become everyday even
worse maybe they are going to Quito for
another reason for a change in the power
a change of president because of the
violence Moreno has declared a state of
emergency striking workers say they
won't end their blockade until the
government reverses its decision
Victoria Gaytan be al-jazeera